[Music]
so recently
there was a member of parliament in the
uk who had uh been caught watching
pornography in a meeting
you mean like they're in a serious
meeting and he's just like watching some
porn
yeah just like right now as if as if i
was steve and i was just watching
pornography
i do like getting a guest there and
playing hardcore just chicks getting
banged
and then just asking them questions
it's it's just funny because it's true
yeah that is true oh my gosh um but
stevie weeby doing that huh good stuff
too that's where he pulls up good stuff
one thing is this guy you know who it
got caught um has now comes out uh he
comes out and he claims that he was
trying to be he was trying to look at
tractors
because this was a while back right no
this just happened it's like he got
caught with his mom it's like what are
you looking at he's like i was trying to
find tractors
at what point was your fingers
probably because it was farm porn you
know what i mean like there's probably
like a haystack
and they're getting bone on a tractor oh
i was looking for tractors that's why i
love the rationale 2000's genre i don't
see barn porn anymore you know the
timeline dude
like a historian like there's a
renaissance era of like porn
are we in now
right now it's the brother [ __ ]
it's the 2d it's the world of 2d
and i think we even passed that man i
think it's all just yeah like
uh what do you call it the the
um
when you when you're when you're like
the first person action i think we're in
the try not to come around
pov pov i mean where we've been in p.o.v
vr yeah pov step sister brother i dare
you not to come maybe
jack off instructions joi yeah
i don't know i think that bart should do
one of those which ones joi hasn't he
done it like a fitness version yeah
that'd be good what's a j.o.i jerk off
instruction bart you should find out on
video yeah
like a drill sergeant
you should do that
here we're announcing right now bart's
going to do a joi
it's going to be 25 a month to sign up
no refunds i'm down and you can't sue us
satisfaction guaranteed though
so this conservative mp who has resigned
after he was seen watching pornography
in the house of commons has said he was
in fact attempting to watch something
about tractors
his name is neil parish uh he claims he
found himself on the porn website
accidentally in the first case because
it was in his cookies but then went back
on a second occasion while in parliament
which he described as his biggest crime
and a moment of madness
because he went back to the same page so
he went back to see it again that was a
really good porno
what he got called dude that was too
good so like so i guess he was like
watching or trying to look up some
tractor [ __ ] right and and somehow like
link to some other porn stuff so he
watched it
and then he tried to get rid of it
and then he like went back to it and
then he got caught the thrill got him
dude so he got caught on the second time
i believe it's not that he got caught
and then was like oh no no no you're
yeah my bad and then goes back
right so
he planned to get caught yeah the quote
the situation was that funnily enough it
was tractors i was looking at i did get
into another website that had a very
similar name
and i watched it for a bit which i
shouldn't have done but my crime biggest
crime is that on another occasion i went
in a second time
that was the sitting that was sitting
waiting to vote on the side of the
chamber so that second time you got
caught
um that's i wonder what the name was if
it sounds like tractor oh then let's
figure it out guys the name is right
here
it's called
dominator
oh come on so he was looking up a
tractor apparently named dominator is
there one called the dominator because i
was looking i was looking up
there
i was looking up um what is it called uh
black chainsaw and incognito black
chainsaw i was wondering if they made
like all black
dude and then it had a name for it why
all black chainsaw like i don't know i
just get a yellow one like everybody
else i thought i don't know how to use
it i just thought it would look cool
you just were googling because you
thought of black jeans that's worse than
that guy honestly this is one of those
like red flags that are like bing yeah
why are you looking at black chase yeah
why not like a lime juice dream try to
cut red
[Laughter]
like where no one knows what you have in
your hands did you schedule this time
with yourself random thoughts for 15
minutes
oh it's called a dominator it's a
harvester
so it's actually a thing what is that
but he did watch see it's a heart it's
for a harvest
and look it's lime green dominator there
you go
okay you were you were looking this up
no no you told me to look it up you said
dominator oh i thought you were talking
about the black chainsaw
i was looking let me see the black
chainsaw
dominator we want to see what you're
well hold on i we did ask to see that
first yeah i wanted to see if there was
a real dominated traffic dominator while
he's looking up this 65 year old uh mp
admitted that what he did was it's
called the black max
the black max that's what you would call
that's basically dan
that's pretty cool right there's some
white in there if you turn your phone
upside down it definitely looks like a
penis it looks like a black dick right
there that's pretty cool
it's got a jagged dick
i don't know i just thought it'd be cool
to have one hero head
igloo cooler in the garage
and in las vegas it's so hot it's gonna
attract so much heat you gotta do like
oh yeah yeah
wow
you should have got a yellow one rich
guys who are bored do [ __ ] weird
things i wasn't gonna buy it
i know that's even worse it's even worse
i just wanna know if it existed because
it's gonna make me happy so you're
saying you're bored no you know how
sometimes you're like you know what be
cool
and then you look at it and it
exists in the world and you're like
no you got to buy it and you're just
satisfied you're satisfied your thought
process sometimes like just make me
wonder what do you mean we're hypocrites
guys we haven't even bought the dark
knight yet see nobody has the balls to
buy the darts i'm afraid that i'll like
it too much i'll abandon nikki's [ __ ]
forever yeah what is the dark knight
look it up
oh no
definitely not doing that you have to
look up on your phone and you can't use
a vpn you cannot
[Laughter]
don't cheat don't cheat don't cheat i'm
going to do it i'm like the batman i'm
getting i'm getting the dog what does it
cause i figure i think it's going to
roll with somebody editor can you cut to
joe saying
oh i'm getting the dark knight and then
black fade to black and then we never
saw joe again
there's just an empty seat for the rest
of the videos just for a new fans who
happen to be here because our subscriber
count keeps on going up obviously
suction device it's i think it's more
than that it's like three-dimensional
suction you know what i mean it's too
much for one man
that's not the black that's not the dark
knight guys
this is just the main core part of it
you guys haven't done the research yet
version 3.0 no no no
see the suction cup right there it goes
up and down that's gonna so the suction
wrangle
it goes it goes like this
up and down
it goes like this and it goes like this
so the motion is this and this at the
same time
it looks like it does this at the same
time yeah there's so much power in this
thing that the next indiana jones movie
is about him finding this
that's how [ __ ] crazy it's one of the
most powerful things i've ever it's only
70 bucks joe oh that's it people are
viewing this item right now raiders are
the dark knight
[Laughter]
meanwhile now i got a [ __ ] i don't
have an address to ship it to for the
last several months now you gotta
address i know now i could send it to
myself
just send it here i'm trying to close
this i don't understand that that's the
first package you've ever ordered for
your new place
that's the dark knight right when you
meet the postal guy uh here's your weird
ass package
thanks for moving in but he's proud
because he bought it with ust yeah all
the come out at once
looks like it swallows it yeah
and it also looks like it shoots it
everywhere too yeah
it's gonna make a mess dude you better
like
grab a hold of it don't you dare spit it
out
a fire hose i'm telling you there's just
too much power there sometimes i think
clintus would say the best a man's got
to know his own limitations i draw the
line right there yeah
no i can't i'll take it for the team
clint eastwood also said you mongs are
all right
hey clint eastwood also said um what did
he say do you guys remember this have
you guys seen this [ __ ] up clip
actually no no is it in gran torino he
says old enough for kisses
what i'm talking about no okay hold up
hold up yes yeah
yeah yeah old enough for kisses didn't
he do his last movie did he like uh that
he directed and wrote wasn't it like a
threesome scene in there yeah i think so
it was like the mule with the hooker
yeah with some hookers it's pretty good
did you say a mule no it's called the
mule
he didn't have sex with the fuel two
people he was the mule okay just play
the scene i'm not going to say anything
just please i'm trying to get the
highest quality which is nice
is it old yeah yeah i mean 360. oh wait
you got up brightness there bud
up the brightness
brightness talking about what's up with
your eyes man
you can see that [ __ ] trying to save
battery dude judging me everybody calls
me amy
i'm corporal john mcburney
but everybody calls me b
[Music]
how old are you
[Music]
[Music]
why why why was this why did you make us
watch this he's talking about he he
brought up the [ __ ] up [ __ ] eastwood
[ __ ]
that was a lighthearted part of the gran
torino
and then i dunked on it
i'm telling you dude what is the context
and that that movie is exists now still
it still exists wait what what's going
on
it's army fatigue i remember what it's
called
why is he an army fatigue why is he
making out with a 13 year old i guess
the point that i'm trying to make if you
guys will let me okay sorry
is that hollywood used to make wholesome
family films now it's gone to hell
they're making degradation they're
ruining the culture
they used to make great filmography
it's
is so [ __ ] weird oh my god i hope
there was a stunt kid for that part
no it did it right there the beguiled is
a 1971 american southern gothic film
starring clint eastwood and geraldine
paige
jesus that was gonna be [ __ ] up dude
by the way i kind of made my stomach
hurt oh i know my nurse correct it right
yo she said it could be the sour cream
but you know he just said if
there's a stun a stun kid that switches
and it's a boy
that's not funny why am i laughing 18
year old boy
no it's the same age
this video is immediately going to
patreon though oh [ __ ]
you